[Musique]
action space présentait aujourd'hui la
combinaison spatiale que devrait porter
les astronautes qui poseront un jour le
pied sur la Lune plus souple et plus
performante elle serait très différente
des modèles antérieurs
avec le succès d'Artémis 1 en novembre
dernier la NASA n'a plus le choix elle
doit s'équiper d'une combinaison adaptée
aux besoins liés à une occupation
permanente de la lune
durant 10 ans de développer une nouvelle
combinaison mais en septembre dernier
changement de plan le mandat est confié
Axium space de mettre au point
d'entretenir et de louer des nouvelles
combinaisons à la NASA comme on loue une
automobile
pour l'agence le coup de l'aventure
était élevé 1 milliard de dollars à ce
jour et jusqu'à 3 milliards et demi
d'ici 2034 il faut dire que la
reconquête de la Lune est une énorme
défi à l'époque des missions Apollo les
sorties lunaires étaient très courtes la
combinaison était rigide et l'épaisse
couche de poussière fines qui recouvre
la lune les endommagés très rapidement
en comparaison la future combinaison
devrait supporter des centaines de
sorties lunaires et permettent
d'accomplir des tâches beaucoup plus
complexes
même d'utiliser ces nouvelles
combinaisons sur Mars
si on parvient à s'y rendre un jour bien
sûr ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal